n
reportage sur les hôpitaux là-
bas.erche
un endroit pour se réchauffer.
En 30 minutes, deunutes, deunuts
viennent trouver refuge ici.
Pourtant, on n'est pas à
au nord, à Mont-Laurier.
L'abri a été ajouté l'hiver
qui frappe désormais
les régions, même éloignées.
GAÉTANE CONSTANTINEAU, coordo.
urgence, Maison Lise Beauchamps
qu'on avait que des gens qui
couchaient dans des tentes d
toile dans la rue. Puis on s'est
dit : bien là, un moment donné,
pour qu'ils puissent
se réchauffer.
- Oui, c'est pour pas me faire
prendre mon stock.
forcés de camper. Au bord
7, on retrouve Gilles
qui dort dans le bois près
de Mont-Laurier.- C'est sale une
que là, j'ai pas eu le temps
à matin!
- Gillespersonne en situation
d'itinérance
- La Sarre c'est pire, Rouyn,
Amos, j'ai essayé tout partout,
c'est aussi diffic
Quand il y en a, ils sont chers.
- C'est la pénurie de logements.
les gens se ramassent à la rue.
que la pénurie
de logement est encore plus
grave ici qu'à Montréal.
Le taux d'inoccupation est
de 3,2 %étropole,
mais il n'est que de 1,7 %
à Mont-Laurier. Avec la
les régions a prov
hausse de 3 % de la population.é
mentale, Maison Lise Beauchamps
- Ça crée un enjeu puis ça crée
une enchère encore plus parce
que les d'augmend'augmend'augmes
loyers, d'exiger encore plus
avec cet exode-là des villes qui
s'en viennent dans les régions.
- Les pl
Au coeur du petit centre-ville,
je rencontre un autre sans-abri.
Comme on le voit à Montréal,
le jeune homme dort au fond
d'un parc.
- Oui, je vais rester ici, oui.e
la métamphétamine. Avec la
pandémie, l'accès aux drog
compliqué dans des endroits
nt-Laurier.
régulier puis que ça devient
mpliqué de se procurer
de la drogue ou que le prix
augmente, ça complique la vie.
Ça propulse à consommer des
substance plus danplus
coupées qui ont des plus grands
impacts sur la santé mentale.
- La Maison Lise Beauchamps
personnes comme Steeve
de sortir de la rue.
Après 15 ans d'itinérance,
il a maintenant un petit
logement supervisé par
Mais l'organisme aimerait avoir
plus d'aide des médecins.
- À l'hôpital de Mont-Laurier,
a pas de psychiatrie, il y a pas
rie, il y a
pas d'infirmières spécialisées
en psychiatrie.- Non, j'en ai pn
psychiatre. Puis encore une
fois, mes médecins de famille,
il y en a un est mite. En tout
cas, ça a été bien dur à faires.
- La pannt et aggravé
la pénurie de personnel dansle i
fait que les succès comme celui
plus rares à l'avenir.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mon